so hi alex uh thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the cheeky science
show
thank you for having me this is great
and uh a congratulations is an order
because you've got a fast author came
out at nature aging recently which we're
going to be talking about today which is
like super impressive and exciting yeah
so huge congratulations though
thank you thank you
i guess a kind of important uh kind of
background to cover before we go into
depth about this paper is could you try
and explain to us what biological ages
and how that might compare to
chronological age
it's a difficult question i think
there's a lot of uncertainty about what
the term biological age really means
and there's a lot of disagreement in the
longevity community about that
i think generally it's believed to be a
metric that's more reflective of the
inherent fitness of an organism or the
tissue every cell
as opposed to just chronological age
which is literally a measure of how many
times you've gone around the sun
along with spaceship earth
so um yeah i think generally in
longevity people are trying to to find
mechanisms and and tools to to measure
what they believe is biological age or
at least some correlative metric to
biological age to really understand how
organisms age and how we can eventually
rejuvenate
tissues and cells and hopefully
organisms to hold too
yeah so there's different ways of
actually trying to
do different biomarkers to predict
biological age but the one that is of
relevance to your publication is
epigenetic aging so could you explain
exactly what that is and what kind of
biomarkers you're looking at to do this
sure so um epigenetic age first um it
was kind of the idea first circulated by
steve horvath in 2011 and in 2013 with
the big paper that he wrote in genome
biology and the idea is that you can
track changes in the epigenome and
particularly in dna methylation and a
lot of these uh cpg sciences they're
called
have
not all but some have
interesting relationships with age so
some will increase in methylation um
pretty robustly with age some will
decrease in methylation some most will
not change at all most are totally
unrelated to aging
but a small subset of these cpg sites um
do have a relationship with age and so
we can use those uh essentially and
that's what steve horvath did in this
2013 paper to create these um
machine learning models um that
eventually allow you to predict
whether it's chronological or biological
age it's still tough to say but some
some submetric that is reflective of the
age based on the epigenome
so currently these methods are like
these approaches using dna methylation
they use so called
bulk samples but your publication talks
about using single cells and measuring
the age of a single cell um and so
what's like the major difference between
the two and what are the limitations of
trying to to predict the age of a single
cell
yeah so as you said most methods ever
since 2013 they've all relied on bulk
samples and the idea is that you can get
the methylome of a bulk sample and since
there's a lot of you have a lot of cells
you'll get a lot of dna and that enables
you to get fractional
methylation fractions for each cpg site
and the other advantage is that since
you have so many cells and so much dna
you're going to get very consistent
coverage of cpg slice between samples
and so you can make these nice matrices
um that have cpgs on as columns or as as
res and then samples as columbia rhodes
whatever you want to do and it'll be
very consistent across samples you can
use those uh directly for machine
learning approaches like elastic net
regression which is the most popular
method but there are also others like a
ridge regression or even some neural
nets
but the problem with single cells is
that um since you're starting with much
less dna there's about six picograms of
dna in a single cell a lot of that is
degraded during the process of bisulfite
conversion which is how you get the
methylone
at least currently there are methods
that are being developed to do that
enzymatically as well but so far it's
with bisulfite conversion and so you
lose a lot of that dna
and what you end up with is a really a
sparse
sparse matrix so
one cell may have a couple cpgs covered
and another cell might have a completely
different set of cpgs covered and not
only that but the the values that you
get since there's only basically one
read because you have one
just one piece of dna and a single cell
you'll have binary methylation values so
cbg will be methylated one or
unmethylated zero and so we had to kind
of
um to develop the method we had to
to to create a framework that enabled us
to work with the sparse binary matrices
as opposed to the classical
dense fractional matrices that you get
with both samples
so i mean the wave describes it so
you've got a single cell and we only get
a limited number of cpg sites that
actually have a methyl group or not that
we can actually detect so there's
basically there's other sites that
because we lose dna in the process of
extracting it we just won't get a
measurement for that cell
so given that we use these sites to then
predict epigenetic age
maybe it doesn't sound like the best
thing to try and do it for a single cell
so how do we actually
overcome these challenges and what are
like the major assumptions you have to
make in the data and what how do you use
the limited amount of information that
you do get to actually get a relatively
um
accurate prediction of an age for a
single cell
yeah so you're exactly correct i mean
that problem was around the first single
cell methylation data sex came out in
2014 there was a group in the uk world
in cambridge actually where you are
and
he
he was able to get the methylene the
partial methylem of a couple single
cells um it's not super high throughput
at the moment these methods are still
basically like one cell parallel
reactions
you can get anywhere from like five to
ten percent of what you would get with
the bulk sample
uh and so because of that ever since
2014 i guess people have been trying to
figure out how to apply these clocks to
single cells because we're very
interested in the heterogeneity of the
aging process and that was something
that was not able to be to be really
analyzed um before this
um and so
yeah i guess um
there's
yeah could you repeat like what
i'm just like what are the major
assumptions like in terms of like the
algorithm and stuff for you to actually
be able to use a limited amount of data
to predict the age of a single cell
so the big assumption that we make is
that uh each cpg site in the single cell
is independent of another cpg site in
that same cell
that assumption is most likely incorrect
i think there's a lot biologically
happening that links methylation a
difference because we know that dna is
it's a it's a 3d structure uh in the
cell and even 40 if you include time
the way it's like moving around
so i think there's a lot more
interactions happening between different
parts of the dna and it's likely that
methylation somewhere has an effect on
methylation somewhere else
but that's very difficult to ascertain
at the moment i think we'll need a lot
more studies and a lot more methods to
be able to understand that and so the
principal assumption that we make is
that that they're independent of each
other and that kind of laying itself
into the the probabilistic approach that
we use the idea of that we make a
likelihood metric based on
the observed methylation values and then
these these training models that we make
based on bulk data
i see and so um obviously as you we've
already spoken about because we got
single cells we don't get all of the cpg
sites there's like less overlap between
different cells and so does that mean
when you predict the age for a single
cell the the cpg sites that you use are
different for each one
absolutely so that was one of the big
things that we had because no method
before that had done that the all these
elastic net like tools essentially you
you give it the methylation matrix that
you have and then it derives you a
couple cpg sites that are informative
based on the mathematics essentially and
it uses those to predict age but
the assumption there is that all these
cpg sites that it choses should be
available in any type of of sample that
you use and if they're not you have a
problem because there are coefficients
associated with these cpg sites and if
you don't have a methylation value to
multiply by that coefficient then
something about the model
will not be as good
as if you had all of those so with
single cells there was no way at least
with present methods to do that since as
they're saying
and what we saw is that the very
discordant reads right so one cell might
have
a particular set of cpg sites and then
another cell might have a completely
different one so what we do
is we create this reference data set
that kind of catalogs um
a fair amount of cpg sites a million
more than a million if you want you can
it's very flexible so you can use any
type of reference set and the idea is
that it maps how methylation changes in
bulk data um with age so it may increase
it may decrease and may not change and
so we use this reference data set and we
selectively intersect it with the given
single cell so that we only look at the
cpg sites that are covered both in the
single cell and the reference data set
and that's kind of how we get around the
problem and then further from that we
kind of rank them there's another
algorithm that we use
to rank and filter them based on only
the cpg sites that we're really
interested in so as i said they're most
of them are totally uninformative of age
so either they'll be unmethylated the
whole time or methylated
also the whole time but we're really
interested in is are the ones that are
dynamic right the ones that change with
age so maybe it'll be unmethylated or
mostly unmethylated at young ages and
then gain and methylation over age or
the opposite
okay you definitely explained that way
better than i did so yeah that makes so
much more sense now um so in the paper
as well you you use single cell age in a
couple of different like scenarios to
show like how it's working and so the
one that i think i liked most was um
usually for like early mouse development
and you see um the kind of something i
read in a review article a year ago
about ground zero how there's actually
like a very early rejuvenation event
going on where we see like the
biological age go down and the very
early stages so i mean could you
elaborate a bit more on that
for sure yeah so we looked at a couple
data sets in our paper um like the first
figure kind of highlights how we
developed the method and it's um
kind of like the
the background for for the rest of the
paper uh figure two looks at this uh
really nice data set from yanvee
where they looked at liver hepatocytes
so that was kind of our
proof of concept that it worked right
because these cells we know that the age
can test liver and we know that
epigenetically it ages
so we wanted to see the same with
individual hepatocytes and it worked
really well
the next one was muscle stem cells and
that was really interesting too
because we found as wolfrag had found
previously that the epigenetic age of
old muscle stem cells is very close to
the epigenetic age of young muscle stem
cells so it suggests some kind of like
attenuated epigenetic aging trajectory
um in muscle stem cells and we looked at
embryonic stem cells nice results there
too and then to to what you're getting
too the brianna rejuvenation that was
really the crux of the paper i think um
my colleague chaba published another
paper in science advances
um earlier last year in june
and that that
looked at this phenomenon at the bulk
level thanks where he first found
empirical evidence that indeed there was
some kind of rejuvenation events
happening
uh and the vadim actually that the
article that you mentioned he he wrote
that without seeing any data so he was
really kind of a visionary
i don't know how you came up with it
it's uh it's a really really brilliant
uh
way to think about it because in fact if
he's right your your sex cells are your
sperm your egg they they age with you
that even if the aging is reduced
because they're they're
gametes right
they're still metabolically active
they're still in your body time still
passes so they must age
but somehow they must give rise to a
baby an embryo that is age zero and that
happens every generation ever since the
beginning of humanity right
um so there's this natural rejuvenation
event uh and we're really interested in
characterizing it um and so we did uh
chop i did it at the book level and then
i was able to do it at the single cell
level and what we find is that the
epigenetic age we used this really great
data set also from wolfrac nature paper
in 2019
and what we find is that from embryonic
day 4.5 which is pretty early
in the mouse
in like mass gastrulation i guess
um from there the epigenetic age
decreases from 4.5 all the way to 7.5
which was the last
time point that we had
and we're at 7.5 it's basically zero
according to a couple models that we
used
so that hints that the epigenetic age of
the gametes is essentially reset not at
fertilization not when they combine but
uh sometime later they're really during
the process of gas relation when the
different germ layers start to to appear
yeah i think that's really interesting
and i think um it'd be really cool to
further investigate what exactly is
happening in this how that like enables
this reduction in the age and i guess
that kind of leads up to my next
question which is like how do you
foresee the application of this tool in
further studies like was there an
opportunity to maybe combine it with
like single cell
transcriptomics um to looking at gene
expression patterns or like yeah why
generally do you see this single cell
age being used
yeah so on one hand i think it's you're
totally correct i think if we're able to
understand the mechanisms that underlie
this embryonic rejuvenation that'll make
a lot of headway to all these other
efforts that are looking at
reprogramming because so far it's all
been like yamanaka or yamanaka type
reprogramming with the os km and that's
quite artificial right there's no at
least so far there's very little like
biological basis for
why that would happen naturally
but we see that it does indeed happen
naturally so if we're able to kind of
dissect how that happens it's possible
we'll we'll be able to find more uh like
downstream effectors and things that
we're able to
to modulate and control a bit more than
yamanaka factories which are still um a
bit uncontrollable at the moment
um and in terms of where
the study and where the tool can be used
i think there's a lot of potential
this is just the first single cell
clock framework there will be many
others as the experimental methods
improve and you start to deal less and
less with this issue of sparsity i think
there will be many more methods and even
with the issue of sparsity i think other
methods can be developed too
um but i hope it's it's used in a lot of
in a lot of applications so on one hand
you're right i think like looking at
multi-omics is super exciting um
wolfrack was kind of the initiator of
that too
where you can now get the transcriptome
the chromatin accessibility information
and the dna methylation in the same
single cell and you can do even more
modalities now and i mean that was a
couple of years ago
i think that's like really one of the
coolest frontiers that science has ever
gone to
is the fact that you're able to learn so
much information from a single self so
hopefully we can create like integrative
models that kind of
that look at different modalities um
and give you a much more comprehensive
age prediction than just from one
modality like the epigenome from what we
looked at
but even just with the ip genome i think
it'll be a useful tool and a lot of
applications to be able to understand
how individual cells age um because we
know like for example like muscle stem
cells they show attenuated epigenetic
aging and that really wasn't um clear
before so we think uh cells age
different very differently in the body
so there might be some that age
kind of like chronological and
epigenetic age like right along the
middle some may have attenuated
epigenetic aging some
likely age faster than the chronological
age
uh and i think more importantly we think
that cells will have very different
responses to
longevity or rejuvenation interventions
and so now we really have a tool to be
able to measure that not at the bulk
level not at a tissue level but how
indeed individual cells
respond to reprogramming or to
rapid myosin or caloric restriction or
things like that
that's actually a really good point um
yeah there's so much you can do with it
and as well we are testing different
therapeutic strategies um as well to see
how effective they are and i guess as
well also we mentioned heterogeneity
like within their tissue and between
organs but also between individuals that
you know be interesting to see
differences so yeah i foresee this being
um
very popular um in the future yeah um
and congratulations again on the paper
um so just
yeah what's what's next for you in terms
of um your research avenues
um yeah so i was i did this work in
vadim gladyshev's group at harvard um
really great place highly recommend if
anyone is interested
vadim is really a great mentor
really a visionary in the field
and he's got a very high integrity view
i think of of things and he's
a really good guy
and i just left a lot of actually last
month uh in december i moved to
california the weather is a bit warmer
here
and i joined retro biosciences just a
couple days ago uh it's a it's a company
focused on reprogramming along with a
couple other things based in redwood
city california so
yeah
awesome and also yeah your expertise is
going to be very useful for that job so
that's the luck of that and
congratulations once more on the paper
and yeah thank you for taking the time
to really explain what exactly it was
you were doing in the paper probably
well definitely better than i did um and
yeah hopefully i think this has given us
a nice
um broad overview of where it can also
be used and the value that it's going to
bring as well so yeah thank you for that
yeah thank you so much for having me
this is great
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening
you